A chaque fois, elle me tue cette pub.
Venez, on joue au jeu des pubs.
C'est quoi ?
On regarde les pubs et il faut trouver pour quoi c'est, quoi.
Ok.
Vas-y, je suis chaud à ces trucs, moi.
Ok. J'ai jamais joué mais ouais, ok, je suis chaud.
Ça, je pense que c'est... Une pub de voiture !
Ouais, non... Je pense pas.
Tu sais, il y a de la musique et tout. Il y a tout un délire de...
Vivez au rythme de la nouvelle Sokoda Fabian .
Quoi ?!
Gagné.
Oh putain, t'es trop fort Aurélien, en fait.
C'était facile.
Il venait à peine juste de dire le truc... Enfin, là, vas-y ! Je suis chaud.
On le fait vraiment, là.
Ça... Tu vois, ça, ça peut être... Ça peut être tellement de trucs.
Ça peut être soit une pub de...
Voiture !
C'est une pub de voiture, ça. Pareil ! J'en suis sûr.
Ouais, non.
Si, si, si.
Voiture.
Ouais, ce serait quand même bizarre qui est...
Tatoya Aigo.
Mais wesh...
Be yourself.
C'était facile.
Vous êtes trop forts, tous les deux là. C'est un truc de fou.
Ouais, ça va.
Il y a quand même plus ouf que deviner des pubs de voiture quand même, chérie.
Je sais. Je dis ça parce que je suis un peu surprise. Parce que Freddy, par exemple, il avait jamais joué, c'est ça ?
Non, jamais.
Bah voilà.
Yes.
Je vais trouver la prochaine, ok ?
Moi, chaque matin, je prends soin de mes dents.
Dentifrice.
Puis je monte dans ma Twingu car la route n'a pas de secret...
Putain ! Mais comment ça ?!
Ça va ! Calme-toi, on s'en fout. Laisse tomber, c'est un jeu.
Si tu veux on peut jouer à un autre jeu, hein ?
Enfin, je veux dire un jeu plus facile.
Un morpion ?
J'ai dit que j'allais en trouver un donc je vais en trouver un, ok ?!
Je vais trouver !
Vas-y, on te laisse... On te laisse... On te laisse jouer.
Ça arrive une fois et on se dit que ce n'est pas grave.
On n'ose pas avoir la vérité en face.
Je dirais que c'est un truc de prévention...
Racket ou harcèlement.
Mais ce n'est pas tout...
Car le plus dur, ce n'est pas de voir la vérité en face...
Non.
Le plus dur...
C'est d'en parler.
Ah voilà, c'est ça ! C'est un truc de prévention, ça.
Yes.
Alors qu'en parler mène souvent à de nouveaux horizons.
Ah non ! C'est une pub de voiture, c'est une pub de voiture, c'est une pub de voiture, c'est...
Mais pas toujours.
Ah non ! C'est un truc de prévention !
C'est un truc de prévention, c'est ça !
Yes ! C'est ce que j'ai dit !
C'est le premier truc que j'ai dit donc ça... Un point !
Et puis, voilà.
Un point...
En tout cas, il existe des numéros pour vous aider.
Yes !
Ainsi qu'un site Internet.
C'est bon !
Ne vous laissez pas abattre.
Je l'ai !
Et conduisez la nouvelle Cliou.
Mais non ! Putain ! Mais comment ça se peut ? Ça se peut pas !
Mais calme-toi.
Calme-toi, chéri !
Tu vas te prendre la tête pour un jeu tout péter, là ? C'est bon. Ça va.
Allez, calme-toi maintenant.
Voilà.
Et puis la série qui reprend de toute façon, hein ?
On jouera une autre fois.
Pardon.
C'est fini, Nate.
Nous savons qui est le tueur.
Je vous jure.
C'est pas moi qui l'ai assassiné.
Obligé, c'est lui le tueur !
En effet, vous êtes innocent.
Car le tueur n'est autre que...
La nouvelle Citroën 500, édition...
Putain de...